we're going to have a look at some
questions that will help us become more
comfortable and fluent
with complex arithmetic now arithmetic
of complex numbers thankfully
takes a lot of the concepts and the
principles that we know from regular old
arithmetic
but as we've seen you have to take extra
special care because these
square roots of negative numbers
introduce lots of extra places where
errors can creep in and where the
numbers don't always behave like they're
used to when we have real numbers so
let's start off with some pretty basic
ones and then these questions will
increase in
complexity see what i did there sorry
that's a terrible joke
all right we'll start with this first
one which is really just about
expanding some brackets so distributing
factors
and then collecting like terms so let's
begin by having a look
at what we can do with the brackets out
at the front and the
second pair as well 4 minus 2i uh
there's nothing out the front of that
nothing to distribute so i'm just going
to write that as 4 minus 2i
but then as soon as i look over to this
second binomial over here three minus
seven is two terms binomial i notice
that this
minus one factor that needs to
distribute to everything inside the
brackets
so i'm going to do this very slowly one
step at a time because these are less
familiar
terms to be working with i'll do that
minus three and then i've got that
plus seven i and then that's done
from here i just take my real components
i collect them
just like i would do with like algebraic
terms and then i do the same with my
imaginary
components so i've got 4 take away 3
which gives me
1 and then negative 2i there
and 7i so they combine to give me
5i so thankfully addition and
subtraction
are the things that are most similar to
our regular old uh
arithmetic so nothing too uh dramatic
there
now here we've got a couple of different
things that involve multiplication
which is a little more intense and so we
need to think carefully about these and
i'm also going to show you there's of
course more than one way to go about
these
especially as you're learning them at
the beginning so to start with we'll
have a look at g and then we'll move on
to h
2 plus i or cubed one of the sort of
instinctive ways to think about this is
2 plus i multiply by 2 plus i
multiply by 2 plus i and therefore that
second one there i can write that as
squared because this is much more
comfortable for me to deal with
now you're going to see this is going to
take a fair amount of work to expand so
when i go ahead
and work out this second term here 2
plus i
all squared you're going to be squaring
binomials
like this because every complex number
is binomial sort of by definition you're
going to be doing this a lot so you
better get comfortable with it right
in this case my a plus bl squared will
be a squared plus 2ab
plus b squared what does that mean here
well here comes my
a squared if i call this my a
and this my there's a squared
for reasons that are going to become
clear in a second i'm going to do the b
squared next and then i'll do the 2ab at
the end b squared in this case will be i
squared and then i'm going to add 2ab
which in this case is 2 times 2 times i
so i'm going to get 4
i now at this point you might realize
why i decided to put
a squared and b squared together rather
than putting the 2a b
in between because your second term
along here because
it's an imaginary number when you square
it you're going to end up with something
real and so therefore it interacts
with the first term that you got out of
that binomial expansion
whereas over here this imaginary part is
going to stay
separate just like we saw with sirds
before so therefore i can now say that
there's
a 2 plus i out the front 4 plus i
squared
is by definition 4 plus negative 1 so i
just end up with a 3
plus 4i and now i can expand these again
so i'll do the 2 and then i'll multiply
2 by i after that so here comes the 2
i get 6 plus 8 i done
and now i'll do multiply through by i so
i get 3i
plus 4 i squared now you're going to
pretty rapidly get to the point where
you've done enough of these that you're
going to stop
writing i squared you're going to say i
know what i squared is it's negative 1
and you'll just substitute that in
directly which is kind of two steps
at the same time but particularly these
early days that encourage you not to
write the i squared don't get confused
or overload your working memory
we can always write more lines to
simplify so at this point i'm going to
say
okay i've got this real term here and
this which is also going to be real
so 6 plus negative 4 is going to give me
2.
and then of course i've got my remaining
imaginary terms which are 11
i okay so that was the first way that
you can do this because it was quite
laborious because we had to kind of do
two steps two stages of the expansion
can we do this a faster way and the
answer is of course we can by using our
knowledge of binomial
expansions if you remember these think
back to pascal's
triangle so if for example i go directly
from 2 plus i cubed right what can i do
here just draw a line across separate
something that's working
did that really messily so it didn't
recognize that's better so
what i can do here is i can say that the
coefficients of the expansion of this
thing there's going to be four
coefficients since the thing is being
cubed and they're going to go from that
line of pascal's triangle the binomial
coefficients one three 3 1 for this row
and you know for those of you who
need to remember it that's how we form
that particular row right
so 1 3 3 and 1 are going to be my
binomial coefficients
and then i'm going to have the twos and
the eyes
are going down and going up in order of
power so let me show you how that works
first i'm going to have 1 lot of 2 cubed
so here is the first binomial
coefficient there's the 1.
then i'm going to have 3 lots of and the
twos
climb down while the eyes climb up
so there's my second term there's my
second binomial coefficient so one and
then three i'm going to have
a three again and the twos keep climbing
down
in power and the eyes keep climbing
up so you can see um i didn't have any
eyes here at all now i've got one now
i've got two
and then the last one here comes the
binomial coefficient there are no more
twos left they've climbed down from
three of them to two to
one now they're a zero all that's left
is just the eyes
okay so now i can start to simplify this
and then my real and my imaginary terms
will emerge so to begin with i've got
i've got an 8 there
this is going to be 3 lots of 4i
then i've got what have i got here 3
lots of now be careful with this there's
a 2 then there's an i squared so that's
going to be
negative 2. and then lastly i know that
in this i
cubed part of that the i squared just
becomes negative 1. so that leaves me
with
minus i so far so good so
you can see now i'm going to have an 8
plus a negative 6 well that gives me
2 like i saw earlier on you can see this
confirms my answer
and then in the same way you're going to
get 12i there minus a single i
there so that gives you the plus 11 i
for full
confirmation so you can go either of
those routes you can see one is clearly
shorter than the other but it requires
that knowledge of binomial coefficients
all right now for h well enough space
here yeah i do for h
you can see we've got this raised to the
power of
four so this is 1 minus i to the power
of
4. now in order to do this guy again
i've kind of got the same two methods
that i had
access to before but because this guy's
to the power of force and even power
i can kind of take advantage of the fact
that this is really 1 minus i
squared and that's being squared again
right so
i can do this relatively simply without
appealing to binomial coefficients
so i'm going to go ahead and do the
inside of these brackets
here comes my a squared here comes my
b squared it's watch out for it it's
going to be
negative oops i should write my plus
it's going to be negative
i squared but thankfully because of that
negative that cancels out
and then i'm going to have my plus 2 a b
which in this case is
plus 2 lots of 1 times negative
i so that's the 1 minus i all squared
that's being squared 2. so now you can
see here you're like oh wait a second
this is going to be 1 this minus i
squared will become
i squared which is negative 1. so 1
negative 1 those things
cancel that's nice isn't it so what i
get left with
is whoopsie daisy what i get left with
is uh
2 times 1 times negative i
so that's minus 2 i and that's just
being squared
so what am i going to get from that the
negative 2 squares into 4 and then the i
squares into negative 1. so you get
negative 4 there
now this is a really interesting one's
part of why i wanted to do this example
because
you'll notice something weird we started
with this
complex number and when we multiplied it
by itself this
particular number of times we ended up
with a result that was
just real now we've seen this happen
before if you recall
if you just take the imaginary unit i
and you multiply it
by itself four times you come up with
one and we've already seen this by
definition of course
with negative one but maybe you didn't
expect that a complex number with real
and imaginary parts also does this
we're going to unpack why exactly you
end up on just a real result
in future lessons so stay tuned okay
let's now move from addition subtraction
and multiplication now we're looking at
some
division so you can see with these guys
we need to be able to use
our conjugates so i'm going to start
with part a
in order to work with this fraction to
divide through by 5 plus 2i
i'm going to get rid of the complex
denominator
altogether i just want to make it real
i'm going to realize the denominator so
i start with the original fraction
and then i'm going to multiply it by an
appropriate term on the top and the
bottom
on the numerator and denominator in
order to get rid of
that complex denominator or at least
make it real
we want to use the conjugate 5 minus 2i
like so and then when i multiply through
by this
we're going to have something we can
simplify out the end so i've got some
space on the right hand side let's go
this way
i've got minus 11 plus 13
uh three yeah no it was the if there was
13. i just wrote down a 3.
13 i there we go that's at the top 5
minus 2
i is alongside it and then down the
bottom here i've got
difference of squares right so i'm going
to get 5 squared
take away 2i squared right but we've
seen this before
when we had a look at this the very
first time and the difference of squares
ends up becoming a sum of squares
because the square of this imaginary
number here
ends up with a positive result so we're
going to simplify that shortly
whilst we get to that we might as well
start to expand what we have
on the numerator so let's have a go one
at a time
we'll do the negative 11 first so i get
minus 55
plus 22 i and then i'll do the 13i
so 5 times 13 last i checked was 65
i and then uh 13 times minus 2i so this
is
minus 26 i squared
so far so good i will draw a big long
fraction line like so
and what i got here this is going to be
25 plus what we have on the top here
sorry on the bottom that's going to be
the 2 is going to square into 4
and then the negative is going to cancel
with the i squared so i just get plus 4.
all right now i need to tidy up a little
bit this on the end here this
minus 26 i squared that of course
becomes plus 26
plus 26 i'm just going to write that
there so if i do
minus 55 plus 26
i think i'm going to get 29.
it looks like they designed that on
purpose when you think about what the
numerator is going to be
22i plus 65i that's going to be
87 i
like so and then i'm dividing through by
29 so you can see here um even though
these numbers all looked weird and
random over here um this is designed to
cancel for us right so 29 is going to
cancel 29 leaving us with one um and 87
is one less multiple of uh
three than 30 right did you catch what i
was doing there so 90i would be three
lots of 30 but this is uh
three lots of 29 which again cancels
with the denominator so i've got plus
3i there and of course you can double
check that on your calculator
okay now when we have a look at f i'm
not going to finish this example but i'm
going to start it
like the only thing that's different
here is we need to deal with this
numerator before we then multiply
through by the conjugate so you can see
that 1 plus i all
squared is going to leave us with 1
that's the a squared
plus i squared which is the b squared
right and then i'm going to add 2 a b
which in this case is 2 times 1
times i so that's going to be divided by
3
minus i so that there i can see that my
1 and my i squared are going to cancel
that just leaves me with 2i
how nice of them to give me something
neat and now i'm ready to multiply
through by my conjugate so 3 plus i
on 3 plus i and then i think you can
take it
from there
okay one last one before we do a bit of
a bonus question
um this here we're provided with a
couple of complex numbers and
z and w are very common designations
that sort of signal to you hey we're in
the complex
field here find in the form x plus i
y which is the normal way i've been
writing complex numbers so far
find 2z plus i w well
this to evaluate we just need to do a
substitution first and then we'll
simplify
as necessary so what's 2z 2z is going to
give me 2
times 1 plus 2i there's 2z plus
iw is going to be i multiplied by 3
take away i so in some ways this is a
question just like the very first one we
had a look at
not complicated you just have to take
care with your substitution and now
my expansion looks to me like i'm going
to get 2 plus
4i plus 3i
minus i squared so as we've seen
multiple times before
we're going to get these guys turning
into real numbers that minus i squared
along the end is a plus 1 so that leaves
me with 3
and then i'm going to collect like terms
and get 7i here for that final one